Well, I am a Christian
and for me by essence
marriage
is between a man and a woman to share a life,
start a family and if they want to and God wants to,
to have children,
and therefore I do not believe in marriage.
of persons of the same sex.
Moreover,
for me marriage is a.
and has the of the.
But I am also
respectful and tolerant of other options
in ethnic matters,
religious, sexual,
and therefore I am absolutely
willing to legislate so that de facto couples,
homosexual or heterosexual,
because there are many
male and female couples
who are not united by marriage,
may be entitled to inheritance,
in the area of forecasting,
that today they do not have them